- [Narrator] This small
islet in Spain is connected
to the mainland by a narrow man-made path.
And fans of Game of
Thrones might recognize it
as the ancestral home to
the Mother of Dragons.
(peaceful music)
Gaztelugatxe can be found
in Basque Country in Spain
and is home to a small chapel
that is dedicated to John the Baptist.
The narrow stone bridge
that connects the islet
consists of 231 zig-zagging
steps leading up to the chapel.
Legend has it that if
visitors make it to the top
and ring the bell on the
exterior three times,
a wish will be granted.
A structure was first built
on the island in the ninth century.
However, since then it has
been destroyed, rebuilt,
and changed purposes many times.
Its uses have ranged from a convent
to serving as a site of imprisonment
for accused witches during
the Spanish Inquisition.
In season seven of Game of Thrones,
Gaztelugatxe made an
appearance as Dragonstone,
causing its popularity to skyrocket.
Thousands of visitors flock
to this recognizable location
for its beauty or perhaps
simply in hopes of one day
catching themselves a glimpse
of Daenerys Targaryen.
(peaceful music)